la parole est à madame fabienne keller
on est vrai que union pour un mouvement
populaire
merci beaucoup mesdames et messieurs les
ministres monsieur le président mes
chers collègues ma question s'adresse
s'ils l'acceptent conjointement à
monsieur le ministre du budget jérôme
cahuzac et monsieur le ministre des
affaires européennes
bernard cazeneuve a à tout passe par le
budget je souhaiterais évoqué ici
l'avenir du 11e contrat triennal pour
strasbourg ville européenne pour la
période 2012 2014
ce contrat tient à la mission
particulière chers collègues qui est
celle de strasbourg et qui accueille des
institutions européennes pour le compte
de la france et concerne les obligations
y ait à ce statut l'objectif est de
poursuivre une stratégie commune entre
l'état et les collectivités pour
conforter renforcer la place et le rôle
de strasbourg et puis l'autre objectif
plus concret est de soutenir des projets
pour la ville et en particulier les
liaisons aériennes vers les capitales
européennes mais aussi le rayonnement
culturel et la vocation de l'université
de strasbourg qui d'ailleurs a bien
profité du plan campus dans sa mission
de rayonnement international
tous les acteurs politiques et
économiques locaux s'accordent à dire
que le contrat triennal est essentiel
pour la ville
le précédent gouvernement avait
travaillé ce dossier et donner un élan
décisif à ce contrat mais l'échéance
électorale nationale n'avait pas permis
sa conclusion après avoir été reporté à
plusieurs reprises depuis mai la
signature de ce contrat tarde cela crée
un climat d'incertitude et fragilise
l'avenir des projets et la place
européenne de strasbourg
cette incertitude est d'autant plus
pénalisante que nous avons eu une très
mauvaise annonce air france klm dont
l'état je rappelle est actionnaire
prévoit 2
supprimez fermer la ligne aérienne entre
roissy et strasbourg strasbourg capitale
européenne a besoin d'un soutien clair
et d'une présence du gouvernement
la conclusion rapide de ce contrat sera
un signal positif mais sur les mini si
je peux me permettre
il n'y a pas d'amour pour strasbourg
i il n'ya chers collègues que des
preuves d'amour
monsieur le ministre pouvait vous
messieurs les ministres précisé le
calendrier prévu pour la signature de ce
contrat ainsi que des éléments chiffrés
sur le montant de l'enveloppé que vous
envisagez de mobiliser je vous remercie
merci pour nous répondre madame monsieur
bernard cazeneuve ministre chargé des
affaires européennes
madame la sénatrice je vous remercie
pour votre question qui renvoie au rôle
particulier que joue strasbourg comme
capitale européenne et aux moyens dont
strasbourg a besoin pour assumer sa
vocation vous avez eu raison de rappeler
que cette dimension européenne de
strasbourg a toujours conduit l'état à
accompagner cette ville dans le
développement de ses liaisons de
transport et notamment aériennes dans le
développement de ses infrastructures
universitaires et de recherche et dans
un certain nombre de grands événements
également qui contribue au rayonnement
international de la ville dont vous avez
été élu et dont vous êtes représentant
ici au parlement
je voudrais insister sur le fait que
vous avez tout à fait raison d'être
inquiète puisque lorsque nous sommes
arrivés en situation de responsabilité
le contrat triennal dont vous parlez
aurait déjà dû être signée puisque ce
contrat triennal arrivé à expiration au
mois de décembre dernier que vous avez
quitté la responsabilité du pouvoir au
mois de mai dernier et que par
conséquent il aurait été normal que ce
contrat su arbitrait et signé au moment
où nous sommes arrivés en situation de
responsabilité
ce n'était pas le cas et les arbitrages
qui aurait dû être rendu pour permettre
qu'il
fut signée dans les meilleurs délais
n'avaient pas été préparées c'est la
raison pour laquelle nous avons pris ce
dossier à bras le corps dès notre
arrivée en responsabilité et je vais par
conséquent pouvoir vous donner des
éléments précis comme je les avais donné
d'ailleurs à strasbourg au moment de
l'inauguration de la foire européenne et
qui vous permettront d'être enfin
totalement rassuré le premier point sur
lequel je voudrais insister c'est que
les arbitrages sont rendus que
l'ensemble des collectivités
territoriales seront reçus dans les
jours qui viennent pour affiner avec eux
les conditions dans lesquelles on
procède à la rédaction définitive de ce
contrat de telle sorte à ce qu'il puisse
être signé dans les meilleurs délais et
ses arbitrages ont été rendus au sein du
gouvernement à la fin du mois de
septembre et par conséquent comme je m'y
étais engagé jeudi sont prêts deuxième
élément de réponse pour ce qui concerne
la desserte transports je veux vous
confirmer ici que l'ensemble des
obligations de service public qui
permettent la desserte aérienne de
strasbourg et qui contribue à son
rayonnement européen seront bien
financés dans le cadre du prochain
contrat triennal et que l'ensemble de
ses liaisons aériennes au terme des
appels d'offres qui sont lancés pourront
être financés dans de bonnes conditions
le troisième point sur lequel je
voudrais insister puisque vous l'avez
évoqué c'est la desserte de strasbourg à
partir de roissy
c'est que nous avions pris l'engagement
de recevoir l'ensemble des financeurs
collectivités territoriales de cette
desserte
cela a été fait il ya de cela trois
semaines à paris ça a permis d'engager
avec le président d'air france qui est à
la tête d'une entreprise qui connaît de
grosses difficultés depuis très
longtemps de nous faire part de ses
difficultés et malgré tout indiqué qu'il
poursuivrait la discussion avec le
gouvernement et les élus locaux pour
trouver une solution qui permettra nous
l'espérons de maintenir un bon niveau de
desserte aérienne et de transport de
strasbourg contribuant ainsi au
rayonnement européen de cette ville à
laquelle nous sommes très attachés